[Music]
there are signs a resurgence is rolling
through western canada we're just a
bunch of people that want to stand up
for our freedom
three weeks after police dismantled the
occupation in ottawa and a month after a
border blockade broke down in alberta
there's anticipation a new truck convoy
may next arrive in victoria at the bc
legislature enough is enough we're not
taking it anymore that's despite bc
already dropping mass mandates and most
other covert restrictions april 8. in
alberta protests still fill some calgary
city streets every weekend weeks after
almost all alberta measures lifted there
are food vendors there are merchandise
vendors it is a festival
they say they're still rallying for all
federal mandates to be dropped but it's
also spurred opposition in the form of
counter protests in calgary
[Applause]
they were pushed back by calgary police
whether they remain visible or not the
sentiments expressed by so-called
freedom protesters are difficult to
dismiss away i think things the
landscape has permanently changed we're
going to get a kind of fracturing of
public discourse a fracturing of social
sensibility a common sense of what it
means to be canadian
and as long as public health and
vaccination remains a political issue as
well as a public health matter experts
say these protests will push on what we
can do is control
whether or not we
flame
or amplify those voices
and my hope is that we've learned some
lessons over the last few months
[Music]
bc and alberta's provincial leaders
stand united against more protests i
would suggest that maybe people could
find more productive ways of expressing
their their frustration i would just say
to these people goodness me get a hobby
still the vocal minority vows their
fight isn't over yet lauren poland
global news calgary